qu'est ce que vous voyez dans ce musée
cds à nu d'accord faut pas confondre
musées et musées m ces deux choses quand
même bien différent meilleure rencontre
des animaux et voyez ici on a voulu
faire sa disposition pour ne pas pour
dire que le requin il est méchant je
sais pas ça du tout on l'a ou femme
exposition pour vous montrer le requin
dans son milieu naturel sur la
biodiversité de requins
moi moi je me lance d'accord mais ça
c'est à la vie n'est qu'un jeu présente
je suis agent de médiation au muséum
d'histoire naturelle et donc bon voilà
l'exposition se trouve ici c'est une
solution temporaire et nous avons reçu à
l'exposition ne retient son milieu c'est
à dire la diversité des requins dans ce
milieu naturel se trouve delà de ce côté
nous avons aussi les mâchoires de
requins le requin et l'homme
c'est bien en fait les rockets sont pas
méchants si justement fait les envahit
on va dire mais en fait c'est comme je
suis donc c'est vrai que dans les dix
ans oui ça m'a plu parce que j'ai appris
vin peut déjà on avait que 5 sont
séduisants avait 7 me souvienne c'est un
peu une sorte de détecteur qu'ils ont on
va dire pour détecter les proies
j'ai appris que l'exposition il ne faut
pas attaquer quelqu'un sinon chacun
puisse attaquer et défendre leurs vies
elle j'appuie que les requins
plusieurs dents ils ont des dents après
encore des dents dernière à leur bouche
loi parce que eux ils n'ont pas de
dentiste alors gr 7 6 à 7 dans cassiya
dette qui le remplace et qu' ils sont en
voie de disparition